bonsoir normand
bonsoir madame dollé alors dites-nous
d'abord qu'est-ce qui cloche dans notre
système d'éducation comment ça se fait
qu'on se retrouve avec des gens qui ont
été qualifiés dans le reportage l'a
carrément des analphabètes fonctionnels
oui ceci très sévère on aimerait avoir
un portrait global exhaustif et 12 de ce
qui se passe mais il ya des raisons
d'être inquiet moi je me félicite que le
public sait où devait beaucoup de
réactions s'inquiète de tout ça et c'est
certainement multi causal madame drôle
est alors il faut examiner l'ensemble la
situation pour nuancer comme il le
conviendrait en quelques minutes
aujourd'hui mais on peut pointer un
certain nombre de choses qui sont
présentes qui sont bien réels et qui
contribue à faire que on ait décollé
avec la lecture si on avait une première
course a nommé une des choses que
beaucoup frappé nos téléspectateurs qui
ont été nombreux comme vous dites à nous
écrire hier c'est de dire on fait passer
dictée ou quand on a en fait on n'évalue
pas les ford en fait les faucons pas
comme on dit s'engage alors à quoi bon
faire des dictées si on enlève pas des
points il ya certainement des problèmes
qui tiennent à la manière d'enseigner à
lire et à écrire c'est un dossier très
complexe celui là aussi une chose ce que
j'aimerais d'abord dire c'est que il
existe à ce sujet des données probantes
des manières meilleur d'apprendre à lire
et à écrire et on les suit pas toujours
une exception par exemple s'est tout
récemment un programme pour le
préscolaire qui lui s'est fondé sur les
données probantes métrage maillot
suscite un tollé
ça c'est extrêmement décevant une autre
aspect de ce problème là certainement
c'est la formation des enseignants les
étudiants qui sont à venir dans les
facultés d'éducation sont souvent très
faible la formation qu'on leur donne est
déficiente et pas toujours fondées sur
les données probantes on se retrouve en
ce moment au québec avec un phénomène de
désertion professionnels de pénurie
d'enseignants qui devrait extrêmement
préoccupant préoccupant est sûre ça se
vérifie ça se voit dans l'enseignement
du français et c'est extrêmement triste
de morceaux on entendu d'ailleurs dans
le reportage et on à faire rejouer
l'extrait tantôt pour que les gens nous
suivent dans la discussion un enseignant
qui faisait parfois ils sont capables de
lire les étudiants rembourser j'appelle
universités mais ils ont un problème
avec le sens par exemple il arrive pas
saisie l'ironie dans un texte comment
c'est possible
c'est une très belle remarquer ici
c'était une des choses les plus
importants que je voudrais transmettre
ce soit lire c'est d'abord effectivement
décoder savoir lire des mots et l'eau
ici on s'est souvent fondées sur des
méthodes qui sont pas les meilleurs pour
apprendre à lire revenons du palais mais
ensuite lire c'est aussi avoir une
culture générale qui permet de
comprendre ce qu'on lit et si on n'a pas
cette culture générale ont beaucoup de
mal à comprendre un grand nombre de
choses l'ironie est un excellent exemple
laissez moi un exemple tout simple on
peut apprendre à lire et connaître le
mode donner mais on ne connaîtra pas le
sens différent à chaque fois des
expressions comme donner un baiser donné
un dollar donnez une injection donner un
bain donner du fil à retorde et la
compliquer suivi complexifier ça encore
vous allez voir que si on n'a pas de
culture générale si le curriculum
transmis correspond pas à la culture
générale qu'on doit avoir on aura du mal
à lire des textes à décoder l'ironie
parce qu'on ne repose savoir préalable
nécessaire pour faire ça ces données là
sont établis depuis très longtemps
l'éducation à s'appeler jean charles
chanat si l'url la dame qui a travaillé
sur ces questions là ll appelés sols la
retombée en 4e année et l'effondrement
de 4e année parce qu'on n'a pas la
culture nécessaire pour lire les livres
et les textes et pourra apprécier les
nuances pour apprécier l'ironie est
instituée mais c'est très grave si vous
êtes en train de gérer c'est parce que
finalement nos jeunes qui vont à l'école
et font tout le primaire ils font le
secondaire ils se retrouvent au cégep et
vous êtes ils ont pas eu accès à sa
socle commun de culture
c'est effectivement grave c'est
effectivement triste et encore plus très
si vous me permettez pour la raison
suivante
la chose se présente comme ceux ci ont
eu des enfants qui ont la chance d'avoir
à la maison accès à une culture générale
leurs parents lisent possède des livres
hachette des revues d'autres enfants
possèdent pas cet avantage lui il arrive
à l'école sans cet avantage que leurs
contacts confère aux autres
l'apprentissage de toutes ces choses
qu'ils ont à la maison le seul lieu pour
ces gens là c'est l'école pour attraper
les eaux et si l'école le fait pas ils
sont encore plus démunis a ajouté à ce
que chez nous on a un système qui est en
fait
simplement
distribuer une école publique commune il
cogne public avec des programmes
spéciaux une école privée et le vouvoyer
s'accentuer des inégalités les
injustices grain paul de dire le mot qui
quittent coup tu touches à
l'apprentissage de la lecture bien sûr
mais à l'accès à la culture on n'a pas
encore parlé des réseaux sociaux
d'internet des téléséries netflix et
compagnie la culture de l'anglais qui
est très très présente auprès de nos
jeunes justement par le biais de tous
ces outils là est-ce que ça ça compte
dans l'équation je pense que ça compte
sans aucun doute dans les créations vous
avez bien raison de souligner en ce
moment il ya un aspect social et
politique à toute cette question look
qui concerne le déclin du français le
manque de valorisation la culture
française le lâche grande place
qu'occupe la culture anglaise et
effectivement les réseaux sociaux des
travaux se font de plus en plus sur ces
questions là c'est complexe mais c'est
évident que ça joue un rôle ça joue un
rôle dans la capacité de se concentrer
de capacité de consacrer du temps à
quelque chose de lire avec effort toutes
ces choses là sont pas prêts à prendre
en compte est à nuancer quand on essaie
d'expliquer la situation complexe qu'on
décrit est là si on veut en rajouter une
couche on a aussi ses étudiants le qui
sont à l'université pour devenir les
futurs enseignants mais eux mêmes ne
sont pas au niveau et doivent refaire
les examens obligatoires de français
plusieurs reprises parfois il garé
carrément pas puis change de programme
tout ça est très révélateur sur même la
qualité de la relève chez les
enseignants qu'est ce qu'on doit faire
normand baillargeon on a l'impression
qu'il faut tout repenser
c'est une vaste question vous avez tout
à fait raison souligné sera les
étudiants annie les étudiants annie à
l'université pour devenir enseignants
sont souvent les étudiants parmi les
plus faibles qui accèdent à l'université
ensuite j'ai le regret de le dire mais
souvent les facultés d'éducation
transmettent ne transmettent pas les
savoirs les mieux fondées sur les
données probantes transmettent et pour
apprendre des pseudosciences qui est
extrêmement dommageable ce qui fait que
les gens qui arrivent dans le milieu
pour enseigner ont été mal préparée par
la formation qu'ils ont reçue vous cook
et le domaine en quelques années on
parle aujourd'hui désertion
professionnels et les facultés
d'éducation ne parviennent pas à nous
donner les enseignantes dont on a besoin
on est en pénurie d'enseignants
c'est dramatique vous me demandez ce
qu'on fait moi ça fait déjà plusieurs
années que je pense que c'est pas à moi
de régler cette question là c'est même
pas aux facultés d'éducation à elle
seule de réglisse haut c'est à une
réflexion collective de fonds à la
lumière des données probantes qui
permettra aux québécois et aux
québécoises de décider ce qu'ils veulent
du système d'éducation et comment on
doit le construire pour parvenir aux
objectifs qu'on se donne collectivement
donc c'est quoi on s'engage vers une
nouvelle commission parent
je les applique comme ça la commission
par à 2.0 j'aimerais beaucoup que
quelque chose comme ça se fasse au
québec et quand je vois la réaction déjà
à votre reportage quand je quand
j'entends aussi les gens parler autour
de moi je crois qu un grand souci pour
l'éducation peut être plus grand que
celui qu'on retrouve dans d'autres
milieux hélas et la population générale
est mûr pour sûr on se soucie encore une
fois de transmettre d'éducation de
transmettre la culture de transmettre du
savoir de transmettre le goût de lire
parce que ce serait très de pau terminer
notre rencontre aujourd'hui entre vous
et moi on disait que l'accès à la
lecture c'est l'accès à des plaisirs
extraordinaire et on est privé soit si
on hip hop sur nos peaux la culture
préalable pour aller lire molia pu
l'apprécier pour aller lire michel
tremblay l'afrique pour comprendre les
chansons de brassens
noël s'en vient ses avocats n'ont un
livre comprend les oublier normand
baillargeon je ne désire de vous
recevoir en entrevue merci recours et
moi qui vous remercie de l'invitation au
revoir on voit